I'll give one of you 200 bucks have you
punch me in the face not fine a few
person can't handle it alone oh [ __ ]
congratulation is the best I'm making a
ton of your friends [ __ ] you
hi I'm Taylor Ingrid remember no you do
this a lot not anymore
okay you need to realize it's just a
scratch you can buff that right out this
is my brother Nick I yeah what is very
good like these people
Nicky where's my phone killers favorite
brunch spot is the Fisher person
sleeping those are just a joke
you're [ __ ] everybody can't need to be
part we don't know kiotas do right no
we're just gonna scare him away
Tupac said it'd be days like this
I'm not a psychopath I just want to be
her friend you've been dating a week
means are you letting you borrow a truck
I just gave him a [ __ ] damn girl you
move fast
everybody kid
oh you watch shoot it was an accident
okay anything else I need to know about
ingress he might have done all of your
company that we found in that thank you
guys thank you for your service
[Applause]
you